sup guys I'm cabby HD here and this is
the most ridiculous pair of headphones I
have ever owned and I regret nothing
[Music]
this is the sennheiser HD 820 you might
remember these actually at CES when we
first got a glimpse of these they showed
up on a bunch of different channels in
the form of a first look
they had like two pairs of the
Sennheiser booth and everyone was dying
to try them out and we did and they
sounded great but that was on a really
crowded show floor you're surrounded by
noise you're listening to the one song
they have available on repeat over and
over again trying to appreciate them but
you can only experience so much out
there and so that begs the question
what's it like to actually bring them
home and experience and own a pair of
these ridiculously high-end headphones
so they promised a couple of things with
these actually first of all the super
wide soundstage similar to the legendary
open-back Sennheiser HD 800 s and 800 s
but with all the benefits of closed back
thanks to the glass here so you know
what we're off the bat let's start with
the price there are two thousand four
hundred dollar headphones so ya know
this isn't a buyer's guide personally I
don't really care pass a certain price
if they're two thousand three thousand
four thousand dollars they're all
ridiculous compared to the one hundred
to three hundred dollar headphones I
spend most of my time listening to but
you do get some insane specs for that
price now specs on some headphones might
actually be the least important part but
just so you know they are these huge
fifty-six millimeter drivers same size
as HD eight hundreds they have a
frequency response that ranges from
twelve to forty three thousand eight
hundred Hertz they have an impedance of
three hundred ohms as you can see edged
onto the side of the ear cups and they
are of course a completely over ear
design with lightweight leather ear cups
that wrap completely around your ear
without touching it it kind of feels
like having premium speakers floating
next to your ears they have this thinner
velvet-lined
foam up at the top and it's actually
structurally made of mostly just hard
plastic but without feeling cheap
because plastic is lightweight and I'll
talk more about that weight in a second
and there's a three meter high quality
braided cable removable at the gold
plated connectors at both of the ends
and on the signature piece is this
concave Gorilla Glass
cup behind the drivers which serves to
reduce interference from the outside
sound and making it closed back and so
the final result the finished package is
this huge absolutely massive pair of
headphones obviously they're way bigger
than you're normally used to seeing but
that's because they can be like these
are not you're out and about type of
headphones these aren't your plug into
your phone and walk outside for
headphones actually it's the opposite of
that these are just your proper sit down
and listen and that's it type of pair of
headphones so that's what they're
designed for they don't have to be low
impedance they don't have to be highly
efficient with smaller drivers they
don't have to be noise cancelling or any
of that stuff they just have to be
lightweight and comfortable for
listening for long periods of time
because that's what you want to do with
these is just sit back and listen for a
long time and really that's what of
course we're most interested in from the
start with a pair of headphones like
this is how they sound that is the focus
and I can tell you right now they sound
absolutely amazing but really actually
the interesting thing with these is
they're supposed to be a closed back
headphone with all the benefits of an
open back design or as close to an open
back pair as a closed back pair can get
if that's making sense basically a
typical high-end pair of open-back
headphones has the classic trade off
because they're open the upside is a
much wider soundstage things sounding
like they're coming from across the room
and a variety of areas a very dynamic
sound but the downside is massive bleed
in both directions everyone around you
can hear what you're listening to and
you can hear things from outside and in
your environment outside of the music so
in a loud space you'll hear that too so
that was the deal with HD 800 and HD 800
s and pretty much any other high-end
pair of open-back headphones I've ever
tried but the HD 820 on the other hand
closed back but open back but closed
back there's this concave piece of
Gorilla Glass over the driver that stops
a lot of sounds from getting in or out
so the bleed is dramatically less the
people around you will hear much less of
what you're listening to but more
importantly for me anyway
you hear less of the world around you
it's not a complete seal it's not noise
cancelling but when you put them on you
hear a lot less
[Music]
so like I said it's not gonna be
noise-canceling by any means you'll
definitely still hear the loudest stuff
but because of that seal all the way
around your ear and because of the glass
it's reduced in a major way it's like
going from a big empty room to a much
quieter sound treated empty room the
soundstage though is still extremely
wide and that would be thanks to the
huge drivers and the air actually in
between the drivers and the glass and
the space between your ear and the
drivers so it's still kind of a spread
out situation which is why the
headphones are so big so it's a very
complex solution to a real problem but I
can verify that it has the intended
effect and the end result is an amazing
listening experience as it better be for
twenty four hundred bucks okay here's
here's where it does it for me for
headphones like this I feel like I can
listen to them at very high volumes I
keep wanting to turn the volume up
because when I do instead of it getting
more harsh or more like shrill at those
especially the troubles and the high
pitches it just gets more full like
there's just more sound it's so much
easier to listen to I hope that makes
sense like carrying the volume up too
high on normal headphones obviously it
gets distorted it gets too loud and it's
hard to listen to it hurts your ears but
turning the volume up really high on
these just feels like more intensity and
more sound and more volume without being
harsh I don't know to an audiophile this
probably seems ridiculous what I'm
saying right now but that's just how I
feel the other thing is I'm loving
listening to these I'm driving them with
an Apollo twin mark 2 and I'm listening
to compress files from streaming
services so I'm clearly not getting a
hundred percent out of these or any
headphones probably over a thousand
bucks at this setup here but it is still
a $900 amp and it sounds pretty damn
good and I've been using it at my desk
for a while I've had the mark one for
years it drives my speakers and I go to
tracks I'm listening to on title and
Spotify title actually this year
introduced what's called a master
quality which is much higher than CD
quality apparently but only a couple
artists and albums actually support it
with this little letter M but basically
whenever I could I attempted to listen
to the highest available quality
possible-- on title or Spotify my go-to
tracks for for assessing audio and
listening to songs I'm familiar with
for headphones contact by Daft Punk six
straight minutes of absolutely jaw on
the floor amazing mastering listen to
that on any pair of headphones it's
great strobe by deadmau5 at its peak
kind of sounds like you're on another
planet say not up by Shaka that's just
one of my favorites and it's also more
pop heavy song as more bass there's more
kick and vocals and then anything by a
vein SIL or C to C just amazing
mastering and that's the type of stuff
that you'll really appreciate on these
headphones because different instruments
and different sounds will be so separate
that's called instrument separation
there'll be so separate and distinct and
crisp and clear that you'll feel like
you're appreciating the song in a whole
new way that might be the most cliche
thing I've ever said about high-end
headphones but it's actually true these
are dope tech 100% everything from the
way they're packaged to how they sound
to how they look to how comfortable they
are it's an experience maybe here's this
is probably the best way I can explain
listening to this pair of headphones
versus a regular pair with a regular
pair of headphones on it might look or
feel to your senses like this like
you're getting a lot out of it you get a
lot of bass a lot of highs a lot of
mid-tones that sounds pretty clear and
everything seems available to your
senses and that's great but then
switching to a pair like this might be
like your senses kind of change where it
might seem a little bit flat at first it
might not be as punchy in the bass but
suddenly you realize all these things
you're missing out on all these
highlights all these shadows all these
textures get a lot more vibrant and
clear it's it's the best analogy I can
make cuz I'm a video person but
hopefully that does it for you my final
thoughts really can be obviously in the
very expensive world of high-end audio
this is probably the nicest pair of
headphones I'm never gonna get to try or
listen to and I'm totally okay with that
and Sennheiser I hope you're cool that
I'm I don't think I want to ever give
them back honestly they're perfect for a
studio environment for me for someone
not that I'm making high-end mixes and
masters and sounds and audio projects
but just as someone who's listening to
things in a studio where I want to block
out high-end sound but I still do want
that vibrant wide soundstage experience
the open / closed back design of these
actually delivers that and that's pretty
so I'm definitely a fan of using out
they are certified dope tech also a
color where if you ever plan on
supporting me is like you did with the
HD 800 either way that's been it thank
you for watching talk to you guys the
next one peace